Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in chapter number 74 verse number 38.
[Silence]
So these are verses number 38
through 48.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Every soul is held captive by its
actions, by its sin."
Every soul is held captive by its own
sin. It is held ransom by its own doing.
Every person once they reach the age of
puberty and once they have a general
sense and understanding of right from
wrong, truth and falsehood,
Islam and shik etc. The choices that
this person makes are incredibly
permanent. These choices of whether
to be good or bad, to be obedient or
disobedient. When a person chooses to
disobey Allah, he becomes captive by his
own sin. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Every soul is held captive
and ransomed by its own sin."
Now notice the wording here
by that soul's own sin.
It would be very different verse if
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala had said
every soul
is captive. Every soul is held captive
except for the people of the right. That
would have been a very different verse.
Why? Because that would sound a lot like
original sin. Do we know what is
original sin? The original sin. This is
a belief in Christianity
that every single human being is born
into sin. So you are guilty by default.
that when Adam alisam and his wife How
when Adam and Eve ate from that
forbidden tree,
what happened? All of their subsequent
offspring was born into sin, having
original sin. They refer to this as the
original sin.
This here is highly refuted in the Quran
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Why?
because it is it is
it is oppressive and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has described himself
that Allah is not oppressive to his
slaves in the least subhanahu wa ta'ala
original sin means that I the son
carry the burden of the sin of my
father. That's not true. I may carry
or I may be born into the circumstances
that led that were led to by the sin of
my father. That's different. But held
accountable for the sins of my father.
No. And this is a question that has come
up often and and sometimes people feel
confused by it
that if we say in Islam there is no such
thing as the original sin. Why? Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says in many places
in the Quran
that no soul shall bear the burden of
another soul.
So the idea of original sin is rejected
in Islam. They did not learn that from
Allah and his messengers. This is
something that was invented. It was
something that was innovated by the
people of the book before us.
However,
the question then becomes,
if we are not punished
and if we are not held to account by the
sins of our father,
then how is it that Adam
was born into paradise or created into
paradise
and then he was expelled from paradise
for eating from the tr fruit eating from
the tree.
But then we don't get that fair chance.
We don't get to start in paradise and
then come down to earth only when we eat
from the forbidden tree. We were all
sent down offic essentially from
paradise when he did it. So does that
mean that we're all guilty? The answer
is no.
Because this because the question is is
this not punishment of of the offspring
by punishing the the forefather when
Allah punished Adam by expelling him
from paradise.
Does this not then mean that we are
being punished too? And the answer is
no. And that is from a couple of angles.
Number one,
being sent out of paradise was not a
punishment for Adam.
It was a result of
cause and effect.
It was a result of cause and effect. To
look at it as a punishment would mean
that Adam repented and was still
punished. Allah accepted Adam's
repentance. He taught him how to repent.
He repented. Allah accepted his
repentance and then punished him in
spite of that. That's saying I
forgive you to someone and then
punishing them in spite of forgiving
them. That's not forgiveness.
So the idea that Adam was punished by
being expelled from paradise. It doesn't
say that anywhere in the Quran, anywhere
in the Sunnah. That was not a
punishment.
That was instead what the result of a
choice
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala told
[Arabic recitation]
the very beginning, do not obey El
is an enemy to you and your wife. Don't
listen to him. Do not obey him lest he
result in you being expelled from
paradise.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala not only
gave Adam the sense of right and wrong
by his he also taught him right and
wrong with command and prohibition and
then he warned him that not only is this
wrong and not only will this be sinful
but it will result in the following
which is being expelled from paradise.
Adamisam made that choice. It was a
conscious decision.
Therefore, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
then spoke to Adam.
[Silence]
So, Adam then had the feeling
of regret and repentance in his heart,
but he didn't know how to repent to
Allah. And so Allah taught him how to
repent.
Adam then repented and Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala accepted his repentance.
So if Allah accepted his repentance, why
did he then send him out of paradise?
That doesn't have to do with his
repentance or lack thereof. That has to
do with the results of his choice.
He told Adam, "If you obey and eat from
this tree, you will be you will end up
having to leave paradise." He chose to
do that. And so paradise he was
expelled from paradise not as a
punishment. It's not a punishment but it
is a res the direct result of his
choice.
Imagine for instance someone commits
someone commits fornication zena and
when they commit this fornication they
contract some kind of disease.
Right? But then they repent to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Does that make the
disease magically disappear? If they had
caught some kind of HIV or some kind of
syphilis, is that going to go away once
they repent? No.
Repentance is not going to erase the
the results of a person's poor choices.
Repentance will not necessarily erase
However, what it will do is change
whether those results are looked at as a
punishment or as a test. So, we go back
to our original
mention here. Someone commits zena.
They contract some kind of disease. They
then repent to Allah.
Allah accepts that repentance, but they
still have the disease. Now, whatever
they suffer from that disease, they'll
be rewarded for as a as a as a trial for
them. That's not considered a punishment
because a punishment does not occur to
people whom Allah has accepted their
repentance. Does that make sense? This
is the difference between the original
sin and Islam.
So the first point is the question
itself is wrong is when we say when
Allah punished Adam did he not then
punish everyone else along with Adam we
say no first of all he didn't punish
Adam because that wasn't a punishment
second of all when even if it were a
punishment
when does something that become a
if you have it and it's taken away from
you that could be a punishment. But if
you never had it in the first place, is
that a punishment? No, it's not a
punishment.
So for instance, we were never born into
paradise. We never experienced paradise.
We were born into this world.
Had we been in paradise and then we were
taken out of paradise, that would be a
punishment because something now has
been taken away from us.
But if we never had it in the first
place, how could that be considered a
punishment?
So hypothetically speaking, had it been
a punishment, it would have only been a
punishment to the person who had it in
the first place, not to someone who
never had it ever.
So this verse is very very important for
us to understand the difference between
he said every soul is captive
by its own sin.
He didn't say every soul is held
captive.
He said every soul is held captive by
its own sin.
Therefore, we are not born in the red.
We're not born into sin. We are born be
we are born as being what? Free from
sin. A clean slate. We are neither held
accountable nor are we punished. We are
we are born in a in a default position.
Then the person by his own choices
then proceeds to disobey Allah. When the
person makes the choice to disobey
Allah, he then becomes what?
He then becomes
he then becomes held captive by his own
choice and his own sin. Not by the sin
of his father. Not by the sin of his
forefather. Not by the choice of his
forefather. This doesn't mean that a
child will not suffer the suffer along
with the parent because of his choice.
Let's say a person has a whole bunch of
money and then they go and gamble it all
away. Will that not result in the
circumstances being changed for their
children? Yes. They went from rich to
poor. Those
are the results of the father's choice.
But that's not a punishment. A
punishment is as Allah has said.
A punishment is only when a person makes
a conscious choice having knowledge of
right and wrong and consciously
knowingly chooses wrong. chooses to
disobey, then and only then will
anything be considered a punishment.
[Arabic recitation]